many brands of birth control pills have
been sold in the U.S since 1960 but only
by prescription but now thanks to a
unanimous decision by the Food and Drug
Administration one version called Opel
will be available over the counter early
next year I voted yes um and I voted yes
because the evidence demonstrates that
the benefits clearly exceed the risks
Federal Regulators say they hope opel's
availability will prevent some of the
nearly 3 million unintended pregnancies
in the U.S every year
if taken as directed ophil prevents
pregnancy 93 percent of the time a much
higher rate than condoms spermicides or
other non-prescription methods the only
people who shouldn't take opil are those
with a history of breast cancer
the major benefits say reproductive
Health Advocates is greater access to
contraception that works many of the
barriers that prevent people from
accessing contraception right now the
barriers that come with the prescription
requirement like having to see a doctor
getting off time from work getting off
time from school finding Child Care the
cost of the visit all of those things
and this access to a pill directly over
the counter will mean the people can
have vastly different access to a highly
effective birth control method the pills
maker hasn't announced opel's price yet
and health care workers say that's a
concern especially for low-income
consumers we are looking for insurance
coverage our our goal is that this is
fully covered by insurance and so
um there are several next steps around
that and do you hope policy makers
um really are able to make that a
reality in the United States
opel's approval means the U.S joins
dozens of other countries that sell oral
contraceptives over the counter giving
more people control over when or if they
decide to become pregnant Rosalind
Jordan Al Jazeera Washington